[Applause]
thank you aloha
thanks to all of you who have gathered
here today on such an important issue as
We Gather here this year we're
celebrating the 50th anniversary of the
enactment of Title IX
Title IX was created as of out of a
recognition of the biological difference
between men and women and we as women
have had great opportunity and
advancement because of it
where we are now today though
is those in power denying the existence
of women
they are seeking to erase us as an
entire category of people
and even more dangerously they are
denying the existence of objective truth
without recognition that there is such a
thing as truth
There Are No Boundaries in our society
which is why we are where we are today
who is suffering as a consequence of
these actions it is the most vulnerable
among us our children that is why we are
gathered here today to stand up for our
kids
to be their voice
because our kids are having their
childhood stolen from them
I think there are a lot of you who are
here who may be able to relate women
here I grew up a tomboy I thought the
boys were having all the fun I cut my
hair short I wanted nothing more than to
be a boy because it was cool and it was
fun
but guess what life moved on I moved on
and I grew up I cannot imagine the kinds
of pressures that are happening with our
kids today with our young girls who are
tomboys
[Applause]
this is what's at stake here we have
people who are undermining our parents
using the threat of the rule of law to
take away their right and responsibility
to raise our kids
forcing compliance and trying to silence
those of us who are here to speak up and
fight for our kids
our kids need us now
they need to hear our voices speaking up
for them
they need to hear your voices of Courage
Your Voice of Truth
exercise your right to free speech
exercise your voice and cast your vote
because who in power matters
there is so much at stake here in this
next election it is nothing short than
our freedom
the Safety and Security of our kids and
our families
and our future
so don't let anyone silence your voice
don't let anyone push you to the
sideline
stand up and speak out because our kids
their well-being and their lives are
what's at stake
thank you so much everybody
stand strong keep fighting aloha
thank you